all right so hopefully you have seen
Justice League by now I know it's pretty
early for the Justice League release
thing it comes out like today on the
nose just fair warning this is the
Justice League spoiler talk I'm going to
talk about some spoilers not gonna be a
play-by-play of the entire movie or
anything when your knee-jerk reactions
like why didn't you talk about this I
probably forgot I don't use scripts
probably should - anyhow here we go
let's talk about it okay so starting out
a general plot is Steppenwolf is looking
for these three cubes called mother
boxes if he gets all three cubes he puts
them together and he can ultimately make
the world a shittier version of itself
making way for Darkseid which is only
slightly different from The Legend of
Zelda in which case Ganondorf is looking
for these three triangles called
triforces if he gets them all and puts
them together and he can make the world
the shittier version of itself but what
this movie did well in that plot is
established the characters for their
individual story most notably cyborg I
really I'm less familiar with cyborg
than everyone else I didn't really watch
the Teen Titans cartoon my real
introduction to cyborg other than you
know Smallville was injustice and even
then he's bad he's the one who's kind of
discovering his powers he didn't know
how much he could actually hack he can
do a lot so he was essentially created
by a mother box there's one part where
he talks about the how there's a
language in his head that he can't
understand but moments like that make me
think cuz I start thinking of extremes
are they bringing in gritter they're
gonna bring in grid at a point something
in his head that he doesn't understand
like is it another presence there that's
not him sounds like great prelude if the
DC Cinematic Universe goes on for long
enough yes they will absolutely
positively eventually bring grit into it
like that was a prelude to grit and hope
and so anyway orange could just be a
general statements like I have an alien
language in my head because it's alien
doing me Batman who at first just
scaring the out of a dude which is
funny because I think to myself word you
learned that you had to do that dudes
like what do you want from me and he's
like fair they can smell it Batman
needed to have that happen but I was
like you learned that at a point did you
learn it before this movie ever began
where did you learn it what I'm going to
call the Snider cut I don't know the end
result was find out because it's like
you don't need to know how he learned
that information to know that he learned
that information probably from Lex
Luthor's notes
I don't know how Lex Luthor learned it
probably from the ship but I love how
you hear a hint of that Batman theme
from Danny Elfman you're like oh wow
that's like mask of the phantasm
there's something about that kind of
fanservice it fits but it's also
fanservice no one can actually look at
it be like ah if that theme just didn't
fit with him
if they do there's just don't be a dick
there's a Batman vein the big thing that
happens is Superman as we know is dead
so now to take on Steppenwolf they're
like we need Superman back the way that
will bring them back which is you take a
mother box you put it in the liquid
relax Luthor ultimately turns azad into
doomsday doomsday and hopefully that'll
bring them back and it works so this
kind of one of the things where I said
there were contradictions and timeline
or events one of them is that the mother
box brings Superman back to life at the
end of Batman vs Superman
you saw the pebbles float off the casket
go he's still alive but the pebbles
floating off the casket really did
nothing they mean nothing what they are
is a fourth wall breaking moment where
the directors literally like Superman
will return the pebbles floating off the
casket really they don't mean anything
because he had no power he wasn't gonna
fly out of a casket he was dead he was
as dead as Elvis which means he's in a
trailer park outside Milwaukee right now
the other one coming tracks for a second
is when cyber was created you find out
in this movie that his dad used the
mother box on him turning him into
cyborg after Superman had died whereas
in Batman vs Superman you see it happen
in the footage before that a little bit
of timeline there in my opinion
but as for Superman it works the mother
box the liquid boom Superman lives after
that he's not really himself he doesn't
remember who he is you feel like his
memories are fragmented he just has the
emotional state is like he knows who
Batman is kind of or he just knows that
he sees him and he just thinks fight
what is this kind of a throwdown that
happens between Superman and the rest of
the Justice League and I thought it was
great because with Ezra Miller the flash
is running pass to Superman how's
everyone the flash was thinking I'm
gonna run around and I don't know push
him over and Superman just looks at him
and he just sees his eye following in
the flash is like oh my god is he
looking at me just this eyeball it's
menacingly following the flash as he's
running around behind him you'd see that
how that would freak him out like she's
used to being look I'm so fast no one's
eyes follow me when I'm doing there's
got to be a mind-blowing experience for
the guy and also tells me one thing for
sure he is yet to go up against reverse
flash which we all knew because he just
already said I just run around and push
people over I've never been in a fight
but after that all ends and Superman
gets his memory back because Lois shows
up and then you see an exit portal it's
just kind of like boom all right well he
got that mother box I guess right there
I was like did he or was there an entire
segment that was cut out of what I will
call this
night Irkut and tell me if the extended
Schneider cut edition comes out and that
still how it goes down there I'm gonna
go ahead and call that one lazy how do
you find it funny that in the trailer
you straight up see Superman in the
trailer the scene where he's in the
cornfield talking to Lois but they cut
it together to make it look like it was
a dream Lois was having no that's
actually him talking to Lois sneaky
sneaky it's pretty tricky I like it but
when Superman came back I was looking at
his face and I was like why does his
face look kind of weird like it's an
Instagram filter on it or something
because I had totally forgotten that he
was brought back to do reshoots and he
had a big mustache and it was like I
can't shave the mustache I I need it for
this other movie I'm doing right now so
you're gonna have to CG it out and they
were like that's cool that's what we're
gonna do so that's why his face looks a
little strange the fact that it took me
out I had a question mark over my head
means there's no escaping this the
people who knew and remembered noticed
it you'd be like oh it's because you
knew but I totally didn't remember so
the fact that I was like why is this
Facebook where it means 100 percent of
the population is going to notice that
however Batman's beard was solid
that was some good man Bush that's
another thing this movie did well is
that it gave you little tidbits to kind
of know where their worlds are I mean I
for one I've seen the flash TV show so
of a lot of people so I imagine the
Flash's story isn't too mysterious but
you know his mom died and his dad was
blamed for it for Aquaman just one
interaction he has with Mara you know
he's the king of Atlantis because she's
like this is your responsibility and you
also know there's some tension between
him and the Atlanteans so I want to see
that I want to see where that goes Game
of Thrones underwater my friends you see
a Green Lantern and one scene not Hal
Jordan but in a flashback where you see
Steppenwolf fight in the Amazons a bunch
of people were brought into this war and
you see a Green Lantern flying around he
gets killed his ring flies off his
finger flies to someone else so we're
getting Green Lantern that is
happening also for me you do see the
differences in tones like the scene
where Superman comes back to life he
goes a little nuts he fights everyone he
throws Batman and after it's all over
Batman's on the grounds one shot where
he's like oh yeah I my legs broken or
something like that this after the fact
jokes are so what Joss Whedon is known
for I have to assume like that's got to
be Joss Whedon right but I would really
like to see someone who did not even
know that Zack Snyder was not the
director for post-production Joss Whedon
was brought in did some reshoots I'd
like to find a person who has been under
a rock who didn't know that information
show them the movie and be like did you
notice anything there like knows
director
one person right and it passes the
cinematic Turing test I guess heartfelt
scene I really really liked its when the
first time a few of them are gonna save
people
that's when flashes like I don't get
into fights I just run really fast and
push people over Batman's like one save
one person it's all I want you to do
flash goes what about after that Batman
goes you'll know and that's exactly what
happens he saves one person he's like I
need to save another one he just saves
people I thought that was remarkably
effective that was a cool superhero
moment right there a seasoned superhero
talking to the rookie superhero and
that's the kind of nugget you want man
just one thing one line that just
completely changes the way he sees
something then when Steppenwolf gets
taken out or eaten by his own parademons
all the evil bad things turn into
flowers I guess I don't know why that
happened really it just does it is
because the power of the mother boxes
and creating life and it just created
life I guess I'm stretching right there
I don't actually have an idea because
flowers are good and the evil was
bad and now we're in the world of good
there are two post-credit scenes one I
would put money that it was Joss Whedon
and it's the one where Superman in the
flash we're like alright we got to do
this and they're going to race that's it
they're gonna write I mean that is comic
book fan 101 right there and of course
when it takes off because black you
don't see who wins will probably never
actually know it'll be like the Apollo
Creed Rocky fight but the other post
credits scene is Lex Luthor's actually
in the movie and it's Jesse Eisenberg
you can tell he's a bit more calm he's
pulled it back a little bit but he's
talking to Deathstroke Slade Wilson and
Deathstroke takes off his mask and it's
Joe Manganiello Maggie Guillen L imagine
Ella
that's right Flash Thompson pump some
iron got swole now he's destro point is
they're gonna make it supergroup
themselves and if you look it up there
are so many bad guys super groups that
have been made it could be the injustice
league could be one of a hundred things
guys in the end Justice League I thought
was a lot of fun that's what I go to
movies like this for I go to movies like
this for fine I thought this was a light
at the end of the tunnel kind of
scenario I thought it focused up
obviously not to everybody so I don't
know what's gonna happen with the
franchise after this hopefully it turns
a profit if it does I feel like that's
what'll matter as we know the Flash's
movie is going to be flashpoint now at
first I was like I understand it's kind
of a contingency if this movie doesn't
land they're gonna hit the reset button
with flashpoint I imagine but at this
point you get so interested in the
characters among the Justice League's
worlds that yeah I don't want to see
that happen I'm just saying pump the
brakes Aquaman also told Wonder Woman he
was like our people we're at war
time ago I wasn't around for that I
imagine they're foreshadowing for
flashpoint so you know that conflict is
there among their people and you see it
happen in the world's just caught in the
middle of it I would love to see Galaga
doats Wonder Woman be a dick I would
love to see Jeffrey Dean Morgan be
Batman for one movie didn't we set it
and have it go back if they're doing
this so Ben Affleck can step down from
being Batman I get it if he doesn't want
to do it and grant it there are some
scenes in this movie I'm like I don't
know that he wants to be there again
don't know if I'm just seeing that
because I've heard the stories the
rumors in the murmuring I'd like to
think it's not true I think he's great
as Batman I'm just saying they don't
want the control-alt-delete man let's
stick around for a bit
all right so Justice League have you
seen it what did you think about it or
what's your favorite and least favorite
parts whatever they are whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]